little cheese pizza day is right around
the corner so we're getting a head start
with bananos New York Pizza Kitchen
Jillian joins us live to give us a slice
of the action
hi Kendall yes a slice of the action I
like that I have my apron on so you know
I mean business but yes we are getting
ready for a national cheese pizza day
I'm here with Chef Ryan at the Hawaii
location of banana thanks for having us
here thank you thank you for having me
okay it smelled good in here we found
the toppings we got the dough but before
we get to our pizza making let's talk a
little bit about the restaurants family
own it's all about the Italian food tell
us a little bit about what you can
experience when you come in
well first you're going to experience
nothing but the quality of the pizza we
use nothing but the best ingredients is
a family-owned business and they've been
in Vegas for over 20 years so
that's uh the flower the flower and the
process we we do a Polish we let the
pizza fermentate for three hours and
then we make the dough the Polish I like
that okay first you're gonna show me
then I'm gonna try but can you show us
the proper way to do the pizza toss
that's what I'm most excited about okay
Chef Ryan walk us through it so
we're gonna use our knuckles
and stretch it out okay and all my
circle mocos yeah oh my gosh it's so
green what size pizza is this gonna make
this is gonna be a 20 inch pizza what
how did that become that so quick right
oh my gosh okay I'm gonna try my hand at
it in a second but as you're doing this
also tell us what is the special you
have going on for cheese pizza day
coming up on Monday so on September 5th
we do have a national cheese
slice day where we're going to be
offering a dollar slice at our two
locations our Craig and our Hualapai
location well you can't beat that deal
and we're gonna keep checking back in
can I have the dough to send it back to
our our friends in the studio I don't
know if they should trust me doing this
but you guys got to come check out
bananas on Hualapai or the Craig
location for National cheese pizza day
that's on Monday and when you see me
next time we're going to be making an
actual pizza so we'll put this apron to
work but I'll send it back to you let's
see how I do do with the dough oh what
was that I'll send